so I had a dream last night or I guess
maybe early this morning shortly before
my alarm went off and in the dream
Donald Trump had succeeded and he
achieved a historic tangible enforceable
agreement with North Korean leader Kim
jong-un
not only for denuclearization but also
for the real substantive improvement of
the lives of North Koreans and in that
dream I was thinking Trump did it I've
been a big anti Trump guy but I got to
give the guy credit he did something
historic and almost planet altering in
scope but that was only a dream and then
I woke up and in my excitement I pulled
up news and read about what took place
at the summit yesterday early today
depending on what time zone were talking
about and it turns out that what we
actually got was exactly what I
predicted sadly a so called the Korea
agreement for completely vague and not
even remote Abul promises that are sort
of maybe going to look into actually
making a reality and I really hate to
say it but the meeting between Trump and
Kim jong-un is exactly what I predicted
it would be and I don't want that to be
the case I wanted it to be something
great we'll talk about that in a moment
to give you the flavor leading up to
this thing Donald Trump and Kim jong-un
met and they shook hands and we've said
before that Trump is sort of drawn to
the dictator types we've been saying
that for a while and even in this clip
I'm going to play for you where they're
sitting next to each other they seem
almost like equals in some sixth sense
we'll check out some video prepare
yourself for the awkwardness but it is
very very odd take a look
[Music]
they forget this success they'd be
commended successful and it's my honor
and we will have it
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so with past presidents right Obama even
George W Bush the US president would
seem like the adult in the room the
person with authority the person with I
don't know some some sort of leverage in
some way compared to the North Korean
leader not with Trump
they really do seem sort of like two
mildly confused guys who were sitting
there wondering what's going to happen
next so anyway on to the negotiations
former NBA basketball player Dennis
Rodman arrived in Singapore shortly
before the negotiations began more about
that a little later
Donald Trump and Kim jong-un meeting for
a few hours it was just the two of them
with interpreters reportedly what do we
know about what was agreed to well we
got an agreement that is as I said
before filled with the same possible
concessions that Kim jong-un has
previously agreed to and vague
statements from both Kim jong-un and
Donald Trump as an example Donald Trump
committed to providing security
guarantees at some point in the future
not have actually been announced so far
if I were Kim I don't know that I'd be
trusting Trump since he's lied and
reneged on so many things so far Trump
and Kim jong-un agreed to enter into a
an effort to build a lasting and stable
peace regime sounds lovely
not actually actionable in any way
sounds very nice conceivably really a
great thing but if no actual meaning
whatsoever especially when you consider
the number of times that North Korea has
said similar things
the most notable element of the
agreement I think is that Donald Trump
said he would suspend military exercises
with South Korea and that that is
actually a real action
although there's questions as to whether
that's even the best path forward I
heard a military analyst say you know
more effective might have been to invite
North Korea to participate in the war
games in some way rather than to just
say yeah we're gonna end those we'll see
what happens and of course Donald Trump
saying that he believes Kim jong-un is
going to dismantle his entire nuclear
arsenal and this is where we really
really get into the meat of it right
it's been reported that Kim jong-un has
agreed to start the denuclearization of
the Korean Peninsula and the language is
important we don't know who does what we
don't know exactly what that means
because the document they signed says
literally just that the DPRK commits to
working towards complete
denuclearization of the Korean Peninsula
and the important language would be a
commitment towards complete verifiable
irreversible denuclearization right we
don't have that and asked more directly
whether Kim jong-un pledged to actually
get rid of his nukes Trump said we're
starting that process very quickly and
North Korea has done similar things
before several times and I've said many
times that the language of
denuclearization of the Korean Peninsula
can mean many different things for Kim
jong-un in the past for North Korean
leaders in the past it has meant
American forces leaving South Korea
altogether for the u.s. it has met North
Korea giving up every nuke that it has
South Korea has made it clear that North
Korea knows exactly what the United
States means by denuclearization but
they play coy with the language
deliberately so that is really the
majority of this thing and now Mike
Pompeo and the North Korean official are
going to be negotiating further I want
to be really clear here I was hoping for
success I was hoping for something
tangible there is no question that this
is a possible change in tone but the
real achievement of the summit is that
Kim jong-un got what he wanted which is
he met with an American president he was
treated like a normal real world leader
with reporting around the world about
this and Trump the great deal maker
the same vague commitments from North
Korea as prior presidents have received
but he gave Kim jong-un the photo-op and
he allowed Kim jong-un to get the
worldwide attention in exchange I
wouldn't have this guy help me negotiate
a car lease he got what everybody else
has gotten but he gave away a lot he
succeeded in legitimizing a dictator
without getting anything of new
practical value while giving a major
propaganda win to North Korea the the
piece of paper they signed is very
similar to the 1994 agreement will with
Bill Clinton it's similar to other
agreements but Kim jong-un in the end
got the photo-op that he wanted and the
big boy meeting with an American
president so the most notable element to
me here is once again not only the
suspension by the u.s. of the military
exercises but also that Trump is at
least theoretically agreeing to provide
some security guarantees in the future
and that would actually be a major
change and the prudence of which can be
debated the prudence of which is
questionable because if you were Donald
Trump and you say I'm willing to provide
security guarantees that is once again
the type of at least pseudo commitment
that doesn't actually put Kim jong-un in
a position of having to do anything
and Trump is trying to make this appear
as though it is a major victory Trump is
bizarrely gushing over Kim jong-un
saying after the fact that Kim jong-un
is smart and talented and a really funny
guy this is more praise than Donald
Trump has recently given the Canadian
Prime Minister Justin Trudeau who's
presumably our ally and Kim jong-un is a
brutal dictator but he is smart talented
and funny in the eyes of Donald Trump
will this be good for Trump that's
actually a really interesting question
regardless of the fact that nothing real
and tangible was achieved by this summit
it still could be good for Donald
Trump's reelection chances it might even
be good for Republicans in November
because many trumpets aren't going to
read past the headlines period they
signed a piece of paper there have been
months
of talking this up people talking about
a Nobel Peace Prize for Donald Trump and
we ended with a document whose value is
merely that they are going to have more
talks but Kim Jong un now has worldwide
headlines for weeks and the signal that
Donald Trump sent is if you acquire
nukes and you threaten the world and you
brutalize your own people you can earn
yourself a face-to-face with an American
president to worldwide acclaim you tell
me what signal that sense if you are
other countries that are starting to
think you know maybe Kim jong-un is on
to something maybe we should grab some
nukes from whoever will sell them to us
and see how that works for us
extraordinarily dangerous and I'm
genuinely I I don't relish this right I
actually wish I could come to you I mean
in my dream I was thrilled I had this
dream where Trump did it and I I was
actually saying I'm gonna have to go on
the show today and say this is a
historic and incredible achievement by
our president I wish I could come and
tell you that literally only in my
dreams did that actually take place the
video you just finished watching was
made possible by you through the
membership program you can sign up for
membership at david pakman.com slash
membership we are viewer supported
independent media you can use the coupon
code
I voted 17 for a 40% discount off of
your membership